parmi les plantes qui habitent notre
planète certaines sont particulièrement
bien adaptées au voyage voici un
candidat bien équipé en effet ces
graines ont dû parcourir des milliers de
kilomètres pour arriver jusqu'à l'île de
la Réunion ses capacités d'adaptation à
différents sols température et altitude
et ses facultés à résister à la
sécheresse lui ont permis de s'implanter
dans toutes les forêts de 200 à 1800 m
d'altitude le bois de nefle à petite
feuille ou Eugénia buxifolia peut
devenir un arbre d'une dizaine de mètres
de haut mais en règle générale il
subsiste à l'état
arbustif c'est un joyau de nos forêts il
est très ramifié et porte de nombreuses
petites feuilles presque rondes d'un
verre sombre sur le dessus et plus clair
sur la face
inférieure la protection brillante qui
couvre la surface des feuilles leur
caractère corice et révoluté ainsi que
les petits poils qui couvrent la face
inférieure des feuilles sont autant
d'indices qui montrent les stratégies
mises en place par la plante pour lutter
contre la
sécheresse entre le mois de décembre et
le mois d'avril selon les station les
fleurs apparaissent à l'extrémité des
ramilles bien en vue des polinisateurs
éventuels elles sont de couleur blanche
ou Ros et sont garni de nombreuses
éthamines de petits fruits grossissent
d'abord discret vert se fondant dans le
feuillage couronné par les restes du
calice de la
fleur
ils atteignent la taille d'une olive ou
d'un petit
goyavier puis ils mûissent se parent
d'une belle teinte orangée presque jaune
c'est le signal donné aux oiseaux les
mères leur ratissent le sommet des
arbres à l'assaut de la pulpe apétissant
qui entour les
graines c'est peut-être dans l'estomac
d'un oiseau ou emporté par le vent que
le bois de nefle est arrivé sur cette
terre mais plus sûrement sur un radeau
végétal qui a traversé la mer transporté
par les courants et qui est venu
s'échouer ici libérant des graines des
petits animaux des insectes ou leurs
œufs mais dans tous les cas en
suffisamment grand nombre pour créer de
nouvelles
populations